let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud proud and do not
give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony [ __ ] them
[Music]
[Music]
t tony michael's podcast
so
we've got a lot of news today there's a
lot of stuff going on
and i want to get to all of it
today absolutely 100
all of it
but first off i want to talk about the
show here for a second because on friday
we have a special guest
on the show on friday
um
her name is nikki new
she is the host of the nikki new show
you might know her from
tick tock
instagram twitter
as at
nikkinu813 she's going to be on the show
on friday it's going to be a fantastic
show we talk a lot about social media
and
uh health issue mental health issues
with social media we also go through
some of the january 6 select committee
stuff
and talk a little bit about how uh some
of these people that end up in the
rolling stones article
are domestic terrorists so we we go
through some of that a bit
so check that out on friday three
o'clock central four o'clock eastern
same exact time youtube twitter twitch
so it's same exact time same exact place
uh you can actually uh will be able to
download at three o'clock central four
o'clock eastern on all the directories
at that time because it'll post cause
what we do with the special guest
episode
is we record it and then we air it
live so it is a recorded episode um so
we'll we'll tease it a little bit with
some clips with nikki over the next few
days and then get the link out there for
the youtube but you can go to
the youtube go to youtube and just
search the tony michaels find my channel
um it'll also air on nikki's channel as
well
so go follow nikki's channel over there
the nikki news show
and it'll air on there so to be on my
channel her channel twitter twitch
it'll be everywhere it'll be everywhere
so come join us on friday
when and when nicki new joins us as our
special guest
but today's show today's show is filled
full of all kinds of things tom cotton
and the senate gqp
are siding with the timothy mctrump
school board domestic terrorist
as uh the attorney general merrick
garland
testifies
in the senate committee hearing
uh tom cotton
uh
mr kennedy mr kennedy
mr mike lee from utah
they really get chuck grassley
this guy's a few beers shy of a of a
case have you never noticed that like
chuck grassley just is not is not there
there's a couple clips of him trying to
read i guess you say trying to read
and it's uh
it's kind of you're like hey you're
gonna run again hmm
it's kinda time time to hang it up there
check
time to hang it up
so we'll we'll run through some clips of
that but i also want to get to that
rolling stone article
on today's episode i think that's very
important uh to get to the rolling stone
article that came out and not that there
was much in there that we didn't already
assume or know
it's just it's just it reiterated and
put it in black and white to to prove to
us with sourced information
of what we already knew which was that
there were members of congress helping
helping plan the january 6 insurrection
seditionist
like mo brooks
uh paul gozar
bobert marjorie hookfoot green i mean
there's there's the list can go on and
on and on here and i'm sure as this
ticks on we'll get more and more
congress people will be drawn into this
on the gqp side because they really
wanted grandpa poopypants to succeed at
his cheeto dust kangaroo coup
so we're going to talk about the rolling
stone article because i got a lot of
clips to play for you today
and one of the clips i want to play
is a clip of john eastman it's a bomb
bombshell video from warren when lauren
windsor she's at la windsor on twitter
um she's the executive director of the
american family voices
um and they do political reporting on
their web show the undercurrent dot tv
so you can find them there they've all
again you can also find them or on
twitter l a windsor
l a windsor but the undercover dot tv
she actually uh catches john eastman
actually talking
about how
uh you know the the the memo was right
his memo was right you know here the
last few weeks they tried to downplay
this because they really can see writing
on the wall that oh man we might be in
some legal trouble here with uh steve
bannon getting held criminally in
criminal contempt these this select
committee is going to take this
seriously see they thought democrats and
that the country would just lay down and
let let them walk all over us that's
what they assumed and we have to stay
pissed i've been saying that the the
last several days we have to stay pissed
we have to stay pissed we have to stay
pissed
and you have to go vote
go [ __ ] vote
because that's how we battle these fools
is we [ __ ] vote
there's going to be an election
in virginia soon for governor you have
to go vote against trumpism
because younkin is trump trumpkin in
that state you have to vote for terry
mcauliffe we have to send a message that
we are [ __ ] serious and we are not
laying down
we are not going to back down
from the ballot box we are going to go
battle at the ballot box and you will
[ __ ] lose just like you lost in
california just like you lost
in 2020 you are going to lose we are
ready to fight fascism at the ballot box
we are ready willing and able we will
crawl over hot lava to fight you
and it all kind of plays out in this in
this little video
there's two parts right now i actually
was not able to grab the third part she
hasn't released the third part of the
video
of the eastman uh memo videos that she
has i've got part one and part two to
play for you today to show you what it
is now you can go out there on her
twitter and i was hoping that she would
drop
the part three so i could play it on the
podcast here but she hasn't dropped
part three yet
but we'll play part one in part two near
the end of the show and we'll go through
why that eastman memo
is so
important
and i want to try something today
because you guys know that i do like
this twitch stream and we we search we
search twitter on the surf stream
sometimes tick tock but most the time
we're surfing twitter
on the stream and i finally came up with
a name board it's called the shitless
roundup
and i i really like the name of it i
like the concept that that twitter is
the [ __ ] list and i feel like every week
i kind of go through the [ __ ] list on
here so i thought if the twitch stream
is named the shitless roundup where
we're rounding up all the things on the
[ __ ] list well then maybe what we'll do
since i go through the [ __ ] list here on
the show maybe we'll just we'll just
call we'll have the segment called the
[ __ ] list and we'll run through all the
[ __ ] that we ran down
on the shitless rundown stream
so we're going to do a thing called the
[ __ ] list here and we're going to try it
out today see what you guys think
you can comment and tell me what you
think
but we're going to we're going to run
through these topics today because the
other topic that i want to get to and
i'll probably i'm going to start it here
is
because it is important um we can't keep
our eye off the ball off the senate and
what they're doing with infrastructure
voting rights
uh the policing act and and some other
things we got to keep our eye on the
ball
with what's happening with this
reconciliation package and this
infrastructure bill and voting rights
and the george ford policing act we got
to keep our eye on those balls and if
you've been keeping your eye on the
senate
here the last few days you've noticed
that uh
senator cinema has been doing some
weird things this is
just some weird things
so i want to talk about that today
on the [ __ ] list too so let's get to it
i've even got a little
i got a fabulous little lead into the
[ __ ] list so so here it is here's the
debut of the [ __ ] list on the tony
michaels podcast
[ __ ] list
all right welcome to the [ __ ] list
where we rounded up
all the [ __ ] topics off of twitter from
the [ __ ] list roundup first up is cinema
is a denim queen you've seen this uh
today this this video i actually didn't
do this on the roundup i found this
today um the
she is presiding over the senate you
know
vice the vice president right now kamala
harris is the presiding officer in the
senate when she is present but when
she's not present or the vice president
in general is not present in the senate
uh senator goes up and presides over the
senate chamber
and they're referred to as madame
president or mr president of the chamber
the same way as the vice president would
be if they were sitting in that seat
and today
center cinema goes up to preside over
the senate and
some people said she should bedazzle the
vest that she had on but she had on a
denim vest
and uh she seemed a little lackadaisical
about residing over the sun and a lot of
people were upset um but there's another
video of of senator cinema that i also
want to show you and comment about and
tell you my opinion on the [ __ ] list
here of what that is but let's first
let's play the clip
of center cinema
in her denim vest
the clerk report the nomination
nomination the judiciary serala nagala
of connecticut united states district
judge for the district of
connecticut
madam president majority leader
so for you guys out there that can't see
on the podcast just the audio um the the
video there from c-span focuses in on on
senator cinema and she has a denim jack
or vest on it's a vest
now with pockets you know a jean jacket
a jean vest as it were
and she kind of she's looking at her
cell phone she's giving thumbs up to
people and she's kind of flipping her
hair
right in the uh doing the old flippy of
the hair
a lot of people are upset about this
because she doesn't look serious but
i'll be i'll be quite honest with you i
think this is one of the least concerns
that we have
about center cinema one of the least of
the concerns that we should have
about her and the reason why is because
there's so many more important issues
here
and there's so many more things that she
is doing
that should be cause for concern of her
constituents other than wearing a denim
jacket
you know i whatever if you want to dress
silly yeah whatever hey whatever you
want to do i if you want to flip your
hair around like you know
this is some kind of uh teen
uh dispute where you're you're feuding
with the other democrats so you're gonna
flip your hair and wear denim that's
fine whatever
that that's childish [ __ ]
right it's i mean it's ridiculous that
she can't dress professionally but
that's the least of the worries here
the most worrisome video the last few
days about uh senator cinema is this one
where she's walking to an airport a
constituent walks up to her and has
concerns seems like legitimate concerns
and well
let me show the clip and then i'll i'll
talk about it on the other side she's
walking with tim scott here
i know you've met the dozens of
lobbyists
i did not touch you i mean
i know you're pretty good at the
lobbyists the world doesn't work talking
with corporate donors
about the pockets that's obviously how
many times will you meet with someone
every single year in arizona it's
getting hotter and hotter we're breaking
breakfast
people are suffering your constituents
are suffering what are you going to do
about climate change
next week in glasgow could be the last
chance
so as you noticed in the video
senator
cinema and senator tim scott are walking
together to the airport and this
constituent comes up to her and
questions her and says hey i have some
concerns can you can i ask you some
questions about concerns and the first
thing
senator cinema says don't touch me don't
touch me you peasant get away from me
you
you lowlife constituent and then tim
scott chimes in and tim scott says oh
well this is par for the course for
these these low-life constituents having
their concerns with their what their
what are they called questions
why or why are we having to answer
questions i am a united states senator
this is ridiculous
i mean honestly what else what else is
your job besides making sure that you're
answering questions from constituents
and handling constituent issues that's
what you [ __ ] ran on
and the thing about uh
kirsten cinema here that i think is the
most important to point out uh
regardless of the the the denim vest
scandal which i think that's kind of
like the tan scoot suit [ __ ] that fox
news does with barack obama who gives a
[ __ ] if she wore a denim vest
you know what you know what they should
give a [ __ ] you know and who should give
a [ __ ] the constituents of hers not only
the constituents of hers but the people
who helped her get elected to that seat
there were a lot of people in arizona
that helped and even outside arizona
that that took time to get her elected
in arizona to that seat work their asses
off their tails off and she told them
what they were gonna do
and now she's completely abandoned them
completely and not only amending them
but make it seem as if oh don't touch me
you peasant ew constituents how gross
not a good look
cinema
and i would imagine that there's going
to be a lot of people in arizona not
just just voters but people who actually
worked on her campaign the last time
that are going to work on a campaign
against her
because of the way that she's treating
constituents and not just constituents
in general the way she's treating their
concerns and the way that she is acting
like what what the constituents are
saying and what the constituents wanted
and what she ran on man it doesn't
matter anymore
man minimum wage man climate issues me
me we don't ah baby
and that's why so many people were mad
about the the vest the denim best
because it kind of sends you know it
digs a little more at that message but
the denim vest
is not what you should be pissed about
the what you should be pissed about is
cinema has abandoned
her campaign she's abandoned the people
who worked on her campaign and she's
abandoned her constituents and that's
why i think it's that's what's going to
hurt her in the long run
so speaking of the senate our next
topic on the [ __ ] list
is uh tom cotton loves terrorists
apparently tom cotton is completely in
love with tears i don't know if he
writes love letters
or if he you know sends text messages
to all these school board timothy
mctrump pumping terrorists or not these
uh this this q anon ivermectin institute
types
but tom cotton really is all in and also
are all the other senators but today
there's a clip of tom gotten in the
senate questioning
attorney general merrick garland
on the topic of the school boards and
rather the department of justice will
seek out
and help local law enforcement state law
enforcement or even the federal law
enforcement to charge people if they're
going to participate in violence or
terrorism
rather it's at a school board meeting or
not city council meeting but school
board meetings are the ones that are
getting crazy
and you notice that we've seen less and
less of these crazy ass videos of these
people yelling and screaming in the
microphones at school board meetings and
the reason why is because school boards
are being attacked by these wackadoos
by the likes of steve bannon on his war
room podcast bannon trader tv
sending them out to to cause trouble and
to
to stop fear
in these school board members
and at these school boards inside these
communities to fear these people and it
it has worked to some degree a lot of
these schools have backed down off some
of their mass mandates and some of their
other mitigation tactics
because of this terrorism
and all a.g garland said in his memo if
you remember about their announcement in
their memo all she said was
is that hey if there's crimes that are
being committed we are going to go after
these folks and we will help we will
help law enforcement
we will help them
if we have to local law enforcement
state law enforcement the feds will help
they didn't say that they were going to
jail people or anything like that that
went and spoke at school board meetings
people have [ __ ] rights
but you do not have the right to
intimidate a public official that is
elected you do not have that right that
is not a thing you have just like just
like you don't have a right to a job or
the right to get on an airplane
you do you cannot intimidate publicly
public elected officials and school
board members are public elected
officials in most cases
so let's watch tom cotton absolutely
lose
his [ __ ] here on a.g guard i mean he did
what a [ __ ] cry baby but let's just
sheriffs to the school board association
of his state in which he talks about
federal investigation and prosecution
it's not about meetings it's not about
coordination about federal investigation
and prosecution
did you direct your u.s attorneys to
issue such a letter
i did not i have not seen that letter
it's got three pages it's got three
pages spreadsheet about all the federal
crimes that that a parent could be
charged with to include the ones you
cited
my memory did maine justice make this
spreadsheet judge i don't have any idea
my memorandum
so there you have it he
he's getting it all wrong he's he's
waving around papers so he can get on
fox news and oan and newsmax tonight
with some kind of rand paul type
evidence
oh look look it's the fouchy evidence
that has to do with school boards
just [ __ ] bone-headed [ __ ] and he and
he it the clip that i don't show is
where he he gets all pissed off and so
flustered in his in his undies in a
bunch he stands up and storms out and he
says you should resign you should resign
and then he runs off crying
because he's a [ __ ] snowflake
this is this is completely [ __ ]
ridiculous number one
everybody in their communities want
their communities to be safe and one of
the places that you want to be safe is a
[ __ ] school board meeting
these are public education institutions
you stupid bastards
you should not you should not be
encouraging violence at a goddamn school
board meaning which they're doing and
they're defending this they're defending
these
timothy mctrump pumping terrorists
because that's what it is it's domestic
terrorism
and then if you've seen these videos
which i know you guys have seen these
videos these viral videos
of these absolute whack-a-doos going to
these school board meetings and the
school board handing over the microphone
to them
and letting them do
q anon ivermectin institute facebook
group slam poetry
i mean they go on and on and on about
all kinds of [ __ ] about how masks will
kill you and batsy all kinds of just
absolute horseshit and you know it's
horseshit just by listening i mean some
people are wearing signs and they got
props and they're sticking they're
sticking spoons to their face because
they're magnetic all kinds of crazy-ass
whack-a-doo type [ __ ]
just [ __ ] queueing on trump humpers
and i'm frankly sick of school boards
giving the microphone to a bunch of dumb
bucks
who are intentionally spreading
misinformation which it's getting
russian propaganda leaked right into the
ears
of our community right inside our school
board meetings
it's [ __ ] ridiculous
and we're gonna have more of this as the
vaccines roll out for these school-age
children and people start to get their
children vaccinated and the schools go
yeah you gotta you gotta get your kid
vaccinated from
come to public schools there's been
several states that are already
enshrining this into law to make sure
that it happens
and that's gonna flip them the [ __ ] out
too you know you know the facebook
ivermecton institute groups are just
gonna have a heyday with that all the
russians pumping in all the
misinformation into those groups
because let's be frank that's what's
leaking out is this queuing on [ __ ] this
q and on shit's working its way into our
school board meetings
an official government meeting these are
these are elected officials if you don't
like
if you don't like the elected officials
at your school board run
or vote for someone else what the [ __ ]
is wrong with you these are elected
officials in most cases
and tom cotton the only thing that he's
doing here is trying to appease the
facebook fans
trying to appease the facebook facebook
fans
the the
the vaccine mandate hysteria isn't
working people are getting vaccinated
they're getting vaccinated they don't
want to lose their jobs they want to get
on airplanes they want to do all this
stuff they're getting vaccinated that's
not working that's not working
the the critical race theory hysteria
and once everyone found out that
that's all [ __ ] that's not that's
not great school curriculum that's
college legal curriculum
that's not working once people find out
what it is and then it's all [ __ ]
that's not working
and then they go back to the mask and
back to the vaccines
and now they're making their way and
they continue to do this and continue to
do this
you know
several weeks ago it was it was all the
the political prisoners of the
insurrection and the insurrections was
was
a tour and then it was antifa and they
always make these loops they make these
loops
and speaking of the insurrection the
insurrections that brings me to our next
topic on the [ __ ] list
mo brooks has mo problems
i've got a couple clips i want to show
you
but the first one i want to show you
is
is
from someone who
months and months and months ago and i i
couldn't find the exact date of this
clip but it's ali alexander no one can
find this guy i'm sure he's gonna have a
subpoena on his doorstep soon if he
already hasn't
uh for the january 6 uh select committee
maybe for this video alone
because some time ago
alexander actually got on the internet
posted this video talked about how how
he actually planned with members of
congress
the insurrection like he's like yeah
this was our idea this was this was the
idea this is how it was going to work
let me just play the clip and then we'll
talk about it on the other side so i'm
going to let you guys know how we're
responding because i was the person who
came up with the january 6 idea with
congressman gosar congressman mo brooks
and then congressman andy biggs
we forced schemed up of putting maximum
pressure on congress while they were
voting so that who we couldn't lobby
we could change the hearts and the minds
of republicans who were in that body
hearing our loud
war from outside
so that was the plan that was the plan
to intimidate congress
and that way they could stoke these
people that way if they needed to stoke
them to go inside and commit violence
yeah you know maybe just maybe and the
reason why we know we know that they
thought there would be violence is
because the ones who were planning it
had body armor on
mo brooks had body armor on
during the insurrection a congressman
who you know i guess wears body armor
every day to
to his job because he's scared to get
shot i i don't know i don't i don't
think mo brooks puts on body armor every
single day but he did on january 6.
he did so let me
i've got a clip here of mo brooks
inciting the mob
into their plan of an insurrection here
let me play that
today is the day american patriots start
taking down names and kicking ass
now our ancestors sacrificed their blood
their sweat their tears their fortunes
and sometimes their lives to give us
their descendants an america that is the
greatest nation in world history so i
have a question for you
are you
willing to do the same
my answer is yes
louder are you willing to do what it
takes to fight for america
louder will you fight for america
so if that's not inciting a mob to do
what they did which was go to the
capitol
and commit violent acts not just against
police officers but try to commit
violent acts against members of congress
and the senate
i don't know what is
and my question to mo brooks would be if
i was a select committee because here's
what i want to know when you were
standing on stage and sighting
and citing the insurrection when you
were getting them pumped up to do
whatever it takes
to save america
were you wearing the body armor at that
point
is that when you were wearing the body
armor because you thought it could get
dangerous when you were inciting the mob
or where did you put it on afterwards
when
when did you put the body armor on
when was it
how long did you have it on and why did
you have it on that's the questions i
want to know about the body armor from
mo brooks
and we know they were planning this this
is this is not [ __ ] new that's why
the world's like a duh
duh of course
of course they help plan the
insurrection we've known that for a long
time we've known that since the end of
january that they were planning the
insurrection but rolling stone
rowing stone
puts
puts it in black and white and all of a
sudden because it's sourced and we'll
talk about the two sources that it came
from in just a bit
but we've known this as planned we've
known it we [ __ ] knew it and the
reason why we knew it is because these
members of congress were releasing
videos saying they were planning this
stuff
before and after
before it even happened they were saying
they were planning it i actually have
one of a particular individual who said
she went to the white house to help plan
this let me play ecklit
just finished with our meetings here at
the white house this afternoon we got
had a great planning session for our
january 6th objection we aren't going to
let this election be stolen by joe biden
and the democrats president trump won by
a landslide
call your house reps call your senators
from your states we've got to make sure
they're on board and we already have a
lot of people engaged okay stay
tuned so they were planning it before it
even happened and they were saying they
were playing it right out in the [ __ ]
open
right out in the [ __ ] open
and even today they're still they're
still talking about
downplaying it up playing it down
playing it up play here's the same [ __ ]
marjorie hoof foot taylor green
and [ __ ] bonehead here's another
there's a clip of her on bannon's trader
tv january 6 was just a riot at the
capitol and if you think about what our
declaration of independence says it says
to overthrow tyrants
like these people can't even remember
who the [ __ ] the president was she's
saying to overthrow a tyrant well a
tyrant is in power
the president united states at the time
was donald trump and yeah he was the
tyrant
but what are you talking about overthrow
a tyrant
joe biden wasn't the president yet he
wasn't sworn in that's not the process
i mean he was already the
president-elect at that point but he had
no real power there's no power what
power did joe biden have what
what power because if joe biden had any
power i would imagine that the capital
would have been well protected
that capital police officers wouldn't
have got beaten and killed
because they would have had the proper
protection the proper precautions
and if joe biden would have been in
power i don't think he would have went
out and incited a mob
either it's never really happened in
modern history
where a tyrant incites a mob besides
january 6 2021
the tyrant that tried to attempt a
cheeto dust kangaroo coo
that's who
and by the way i
someone um sent some pictures
on twitter
and i don't know why these pictures are
side by side it's a picture of marjorie
taylor green and someone else let me
show that you can see here i'm not sure
what that's about um but this is a
picture from that clip i just showed and
they posted the picture of
someone carrying like a backpack i don't
know maybe it looks pretty heavy
like they might have some heavy objects
in the backpack
and a sweater on i don't know i don't
know why someone sent this to me our
senate put it on twitter i i don't know
i guess you could draw your own
conclusions do your own
research right that's what we need to do
is do our own research and speaking of
research i want to get to this rolling
stones article and then get to the
eastman videos
but i'm going to do something special
here that we've never done on the show
which is take a break this is the first
break and when we come back
we'll look at parts of the rolling
stones uh article we'll talk about it
and we'll also go over part one
and part two
of the eastman videos from lauren
windsor
you sit your ass down sit the flip down
we're not finished the tony michaels
podcast we'll be right back
i am so excited about a new movie you
guys have probably heard about this
movie the supporters it's starring the
good liars this movie is [ __ ]
hilarious and i think it might have been
a mistake but for some reason i got an
advanced screening of this movie it's
about two doofuses that get wrapped up
in the mug of trump bumping gulp [ __ ]
boneheads the characters names are
derrick and dale and they have a podcast
called the derrick and dale show that
they do out of the back of a minivan
that they live out of they're pissing
and jugs
they're chasing their dreams of having
this hit cable show on fox news and when
that all gets crushed they decide to do
their own research and travel all across
the country during the 2020 presidential
campaign armed with only their white
male fragility and a camera
they run into the likes of andrew yang
tom steyer elizabeth warren president
joe biden marjorie hoof foot green don
booger sugar junior they even have a
close encounter in the film with the
cheeto dust mobster grandpa poopypants
himself donald trump is in the film you
cannot miss this one it is a
fantastically funny movie starring the
good liars you know these comedians from
their viral videos about occupy wall
street maga rallies and even the january
6 insurrection that footage from the
january 6 insurrection is in the film do
not miss this movie it is released on
november 4th go to
thesupportersmovie.com in reserve so you
see the movie first you have to see this
[ __ ] movie the good liars present in
association with midas pictures
executive producers michael rappaport
the
supporters don't
[ __ ] miss it
[Music]
the tony michaels podcast wednesdays at
4 p.m eastern 3 pm central watch live on
youtube on twitter and twitch download
on apple and spotify now here's tony
[Music]
welcome back
to the tony michaels podcast
what do you think about that movie
it's a good one i'll tell you i got the
advanced screening i was really
surprised when they sent it to me
and i watched the movie and i did the
review
because uh it's a hilarious movie you
gotta check it out it comes out on
november 4th uh the midas touch and
michael rappaport actually produced the
video it's from the good it's by the
good liars or are the ones who in it
they do a lot of videos you guys surely
have seen some of these videos that they
go around to manga rallies they went to
january 6 insurrection and some of that
footage like i said in the review it's
actually in the film which is some of
the interesting footage uh
but also some of the other footage that
you've that that's in the film you might
have seen from some of their viral
videos because they do go around the the
2020 campaign because they don't just
kind of punk uh the republicans they
kind of they kind of do it to the
democrats too which is uh all in good
fun it's it's a hilarious movie you
really gotta check it out again just go
to
thesupportersmovie.com and check that
out it's uh it's gonna be it's gonna be
a hilarious hilarious movie it is
hilarious movie i've watched it it's
it's hilarious it's it's fantastic
there's there's a lot of good stuff in
it so go check that out but back to
the [ __ ] list
[ __ ] list
so i told you we were gonna talk about
this rolling stone article
about these fascist rolling stones
these congress people as they are you
see how i played on the words there
fascist rolling stones for you guys out
there not uh
you just listen you can't see that
shitless graphic it says fascist rolling
stones that's that's that's the play
there that these
seditionists which is what they are
are fascist rolling stones from the
rolling stone article but i want to show
you a couple of excerpts from
rollingstone.com of the article the
first one here it actually breaks down
the
representatives
that are in this conspiracy
to
have conversations with other organizers
so if you haven't read the article you
can go over to rollingstone.com
um it talks about how there are two
possibly three but two people who have
received immunity from the january 6
select committee to give their testimony
on how they planned and organized with
members of congress to overthrow the
government of the united states
and along with marjorie taylor green
which we just saw clips of and a picture
of the one picture i don't know about
the other picture i don't know why it's
they're together but but marjorie taylor
green is one
that communicated with these people but
also paul gozar lauren bobert mo brooks
madison cawthorne andy biggs and louie
gohmert
and the planners who are testifying and
giving this testimony and these
depositions to the january 6
select committee where they received
immunity for this deposition
is they they are quoted to say we would
talk to bobert's team
cawthorne's team goes arts team like
back to back to back
meaning they're not just like
coordinating with one of them
they're all coordinating together
there's a big huge conspiracy here for
not just the organizers of the violent
insurrection these groups like uh for
example some of the groups that were
there that day are proud boys the oath
keepers
that they're planning with them
to overthrow the constitution of the
united states and disrupt the
constitutional power that the joint
session had
that's the thing here
is these people
are part of the planning and we've known
this
we've known this again we've seen the
video of marjorie taylor green before
the insurrection where she's saying
we're planning we're planning and she
was at the white house
and i think that's really the reason why
steve bannon's
testimony and deposition and records
that
the january select committee has
subpoenaed
is his communications with the cheeto
dust mobster
because i would imagine that grandpa
poopy pants and all his
movie fantasy ways he always acts like
this mobster he ever noticed that how he
community he never knows anybody
remember how michael cohen was a great
guy until he wasn't
leb parnez was a great guy until he was
just a guy in a picture with him rudy
giuliani was fantastic rudy giuliani was
his attorney how rudy giuliani was going
around working so hard for him all
around the country to sell the big lie
that [ __ ] was dripping out of his head
running [ __ ] was running down his face
he was sh he was sweating [ __ ] that's
how hard giuliani was working for trump
to sell the big lie
i mean jesus he didn't even have time
to take a break he farted on jenna ellis
running around testifying in front of
state
state committees so much so he lost his
law license because he's a [ __ ] loser
anyone who's trump or associated trump
ends up being a total [ __ ] loser
but we see it there
we see it
there
so we know that this planning was going
on
with lauren bobert marjorie taylor green
because there was already whiffs and
reports of people giving tours when
there weren't any official tours of the
capitol other members of congress were
like hey i saw that person giving tours
to those people who were in here the
next day
breaking windows and threatening to kill
cut members of congress
and apparently some of those people
some of those people
are talking to the january sixth select
committee and the reason why they're
talking to the january select committee
is because they're [ __ ] pissed
now they love the insurrection you know
they love they love being trump humpers
and timothy mctrump pumping
terrorists domestic terrorists they love
that they love it
it's right wing type [ __ ]
it's right that's what fascists love
they love political violence that's what
they love
they love to incite political violence
it's them over the right wing but
they're getting pissed and the reason
why they're getting pissed is because
they're seeing people like steve bannon
who they talk to
that's the whole point
steve bannon was a liaison to president
trump why do you think they're trying to
claim executive privilege for that
communication
that's the communication that the
rolling stones is talking about more
than likely
is the communication that was being
communicated from these groups who carry
out the insurrection
was working its way from these congress
members to liaisons to the president
not in some well inside the
administration but outside the
administration in the way of steve
bannon and roger stone
and they were relaying those messages to
the president of the united states
grandpa poopy pants himself donald trump
that way he could say well i don't know
who these people are i never talked to
such and such and i never talked to who
and who and i don't know that person and
i take lots of pictures and i get lots
of diet cokes and big macs people give
me all the time i don't know those
people i don't know them that's a
mobster type thing
la costa nostra
the mob the mafia that's what they do
you know they have their henchmen go out
and organize and come back and report so
they're not part of the communication
they're not part of the conspiracy as it
were
but that's what rico laws are for that's
what this chain of command laws are for
that's what the select committee wants
to know that communication between steve
bannon and the president united states
donald j trump at the time of the
january 6th insurrection that they are
investigating that's why that
communication is [ __ ] important
they want to know what was being relayed
to
grandpa poopy pants
from these
groups that were organizing the violent
insurrection
if mike pence wouldn't do what they
wanted him to do which was make the
cheeto dust mobster mobster the mango
mussolini jesus the king if he wouldn't
do that a power which he did not have
but if he would not do that
they would laid siege on the capital
which they did it didn't work but they
tried
they tried the cheeto dust kangaroo
they tried it
and the january select committee just
wants to know
where did all that communication work
its way up
and i believe that's why not just steve
bannon but donald trump is claiming
executive privilege on that
communication because that communication
will show it will show
it will show
that this rolling stone article just
doesn't have to do with these members of
congress
it also has to do with steve bannon it
also has to do with the cheeto dust
mobster grandpa poopypants donald trump
and others inside the administration
mark meadows
dan scavino outside the administration
roger stone steve bannon
donald donald trump jr
they were all players and to organize
a violent siege on the capitol if they
didn't get what they wanted because
that's what they do folks that's what
these trump pumping fools do
is they cry and whine and when they
don't get their way they act out
[ __ ] snowflakes
so let's go to the second part of the
rolling stone article here because i
want to get to the eastman videos here
you see uh in the article that goes are
one of the most prominent defenders of
the january 6 insurrectionist the
timothy mc trump pumping terrorist
he was trying to get a blanket pardon
and that's how he was kind of inciting
him to plan
to plan the insurrection if they didn't
if it didn't go their way
and the organizers who were testifying
to the january slick
six committee the select committee
is that they're they're saying the ones
that have immunity they're saying that
their impression was that the deal was
done that they'd spoke to the mango
mussolini jesus and he had anointed them
pardoned
and that that is why these people ran to
the capitol they kept planning
it's because they were promised
they were promised blanket pardons so in
other words you can do whatever you want
as long as you make me king as long as
whatever you do makes me king i'll save
your ass in a federal court
that's what that's what he was saying
[ __ ] ridiculous now i believe that
there's more to this story than just
what the rolling stone article is saying
about the congress people again i think
steve bannon roger stone and there's
some other liaisons that are between the
communication of the organizing groups
and
and the dictator to be grandpa
poopypants
when they were planning the cheeto dust
kangaroo coup
now
the thing that stands out to me the most
and today we had a drop from lorne
windsor on the internet
of john eastman you remember this
character in the story john eastman
wrote a legal memo basically saying yeah
sure mike pence has the power to
deem donald trump the dictator of the
united states of america
mike pence has the sole power of
overturning the constitution of the
united states by overturning the will of
the voters and the will of the states
who certified the votes
he has that power
in basic terms now the last few weeks
john eastman has walked away from that
narrative he's running away from it and
the reason why he's running away from us
because bannon's been held in criminal
contempt here for those communications
that he has possible communications with
who possibly those members of congress
which is about possibly the planning of
the january 6 insurrection
the cheeto dust kangaroo coup
so john eastman lays it out in his memo
but again
he starts to walk away from it or does
he
or does he walk away from it he's trying
to walk away from it in the press
but does he actually walk away from him
because i think lauren windsor has a
great scoop here on these videos because
it is obvious that that john eastman is
not walking away from his minimum he
believes every goddamn q and on word in
his in his memo
john eastman is now
a queuing on her basically i mean that's
what these [ __ ] theories are in the
videos that lauren windsor overturn
under um uncovers here
it's almost like
q anon
ate donald trump's brain and had john
eastmans for dessert
i guess that's what happens when you get
lynnwood sydney powell mike flynn and
mike lindell
all in the same room
they feast on your intellect
holy [ __ ]
but these videos that lauren windsor
ever has released today part one and
part two and i don't know it's possible
that she's released part three at this
point i did not have part three coming
on the show here i really was hoping she
would release it but she has not so i
don't know what's in part three but i
know what's in one or two and we're
gonna play him here so let's hang tight
but these videos really reveal that the
press that john eastman is trying to do
and that the tr the trump allies are
trying to do that that memo was all
[ __ ] no one would believe it no one
in their right mind would believe what
that what no one in the right mind would
believe what that memo said there's no
way anyone possibly could believe that
[ __ ] well apparently john eastman
[ __ ] does
because in this [ __ ] video
that that's basically the crux of it is
yep
so let me show you the video and then
we'll talk about it on the other side
we're huge trump supporters and we were
actually at january 6. oh yeah we saw
your good night
should i incite you to go down to the
capitol and riot you actually incited us
to become supporters of claremont oh
good very good very good because you
know and the work that you're doing is
so critical to saving our democracy and
it was like
we couldn't not support your work after
that okay well thank you very much
that's very kind of you so thank you
you're really doing the lord's work well
and i you know uh that's why you heard
me say it my old professor said if
you're not catching incoming plaque
you're not over the target and my god i
must be directly over it because you
know i i don't think there's anybody
catch as much incoming flack maybe then
other than trump himself that i have
over the last six months i mean it's
amazing well but i read your memo and i
thought it was solid in all of its legal
arguments
i just i was floored that
that mike pence
didn't do anything i mean why
didn't he act on it because you gave him
the legal reasoning to do that i know i
know no it's and now in a piece in the
atlantic two days ago
they're already anticipating trump
winning in
2024 and they're using my arguments from
that memo that they all said had no
credibility to argue that pamela harris
can block trump's electoral votes i mean
it's like
you know it's like i mean come on people
basically everyone's gonna say you're
being proven right yeah exactly exactly
except they're not saying that right but
that's what they mean yeah exactly
exactly all of your legal reasoning is
totally solid yeah yeah there's no
question but uh
but i mean like you know just supported
his supporter like why do you think that
mike pence didn't do it well because
mike pence is an establishment guy at
the end of the day and
all of the establishment republicans in
dc
fought into this very myopic view
that trump was destroying the republican
party and what trump was doing is
destroying the inside the beltway
republican party
and reviving the republican party in the
hinterland right what they all consider
the you know deplorable flyover country
and this uprising that trump got ahead
of he didn't create the movement the
movement was there yeah and he saw it
and got ahead of it
um but no that's they can't tolerate
that because they all they all have nice
cushy livings inside the beltway
so
a couple things about this video number
one at the beginning he's like oh did i
incite you to a riot
he's joking but really the substance of
this is that he does believe that
[ __ ] memo he believes that memo he
believes that not only not only did mike
pence have the complete legal right to
overturn the election
just one person has the power to
overturn the election but he believed he
pushed out you [ __ ] you pushed out you
didn't do what you were supposed to do
because you're scared of the
establishment
as if as if right now the gqp is
terrified of the establishment what the
[ __ ] are you talking about the
establishment in the gqp is dead dead
dead dead
like a like a
it's dead and that vultures are coming
to get it
that's what's happening [ __ ] roadkill
because trump killed it even lindsey
graham said back in 2016 if he's the
party he'll destroy it and he did he did
and eastman lays it out right here in
this [ __ ] video
he says
this this was trump knew this was the
undercurrent of the republican party
this has been
been there the entire time trump just
uncovered it
this fascist hint and i believe he's
correct i believe he's correct trump did
uncover
the thin veiled fascism then veiled with
conservatism and tea party and all that
[ __ ] just a bunch of [ __ ]
nonsense they never believed any of that
[ __ ] just like they don't believe
anything else they don't have any
[ __ ] principles
they don't have principle one
they can't decide what's up and what's
down most days the [ __ ] out of here
and yeah he did tap into it he did
uncover it because it was there this
fascism
that was
that was deeply rooted in white america
and trump uncovered it with racism and
hate and fear
that's true
so if that's true and eastman's on to
something there maybe he's on to
something that mike pence pushed out
that they were pressuring mike pence
because that's a reports that we have
that the present united states
the mango mussolini jesus
and others including eastman giuliani
and others were pressuring
mike pence
to do what he had to do to make
sure the grandpa poopypants stay
dictator of the united states of america
that's what we know
so she has a second a second part of
this video now again i she has a third
part and i don't have it here but i i'm
gonna play the second part for you and
then
we'll talk about that again on the other
end like trump came down like on the
sticks like
things changed a little bit if he came
down yeah he said he was coming down oh
down to the capitol yeah i don't yeah i
don't know because because
the the
the breaking of the windows stuff had
already started before his speech was
over
and if he got if he got down there then
all of that would have been blamed on
him i mean they're still blaming it but
they would have had more bases for it
so i you know he'd been planning on
coming down though yeah i know i know i
know so yeah
the whole thing was a setup i mean it
was a setup uh john
sullivan
antica guy got paid 60 000 bucks by cnn
to break in and get video of violence
right this is a fact
the oath keepers and the proud boys had
not just kind of
wallflowers sitting on the side of the
organization but people instigating
within the association
fbi
uh plans
these were it was a setup and and you
know unfortunately our guys walked into
the track
but so he would have gone down there if
it hadn't been for the violin
like he he decided not to go because
people were
engaging in violence and breaking stuff
yeah because i mean he didn't want that
right no and he and he immediately
tweeted out
what he said on his speech go down there
peacefully and patriotically and let
your voices be heard right that's what
he said
so in this video this is where all this
q and on trump humping crazy ass [ __ ]
comes out
where he's it's talking about antifa and
[ __ ] the fbi and it's always someone
else's fault with these [ __ ]
it's never trump's fault you notice that
oh yeah he well he was i mean he planned
he planned on um
joining you but he pushed out just he
does what they project everyone else
doing so here in these videos in these
clips
john eastman is claiming that
mike pence wouldn't do what it took to
save america but donald trump wouldn't
took what it did to save america he
wouldn't get off his fat and infested
ass and walk down to the capitol
and demand that they make him dictator
he wasn't willing to do that
you know i don't know maybe maybe maybe
it's a far walk
for that fat slob just too far of a walk
but it really does seem rich that
they're blaming mike pence for not doing
the right thing because of the
establishment
but here's john eastman saying ah well
trump couldn't go because there was
broken windows and now you know this and
that and
always projection with these [ __ ]
and then you break down some of the
setup oh we were set up
set up for what what are you talking
about set up
look the [ __ ] joint session to
certify the vote is ceremonial
you got it it's ceremonial it doesn't
even mean [ __ ] they come up with this
garbage after the civil war to make
congress feel [ __ ] special to make
the north and the south look like they
were on the same page so that the
federal government could anoint the next
president
the south and the north together as
opposed to just going by the state
certifying the vote the states had
already certified the vote the election
was [ __ ] over
as of january 20th at noon the cheeto
dust monster donald trump was not going
to be president nada
regardless if he won or not he had to be
re-sworn in even if he would have won
the presidency only lasts for a certain
term
it doesn't last forever
that's not a thing just because there's
not another president the constitution
calls for how we would determine who the
next president was if we didn't have a
winner in the in the in the electoral
vote
you got it
on january 20th someone was going to be
sworn in other than donald trump as the
president united states and that person
was the person who won the election and
the state certified won the election joe
biden that's why this eastman memo is
all a bunch of horseshit
it's all a bunch of horseshit and this
idea
that they had for the eastman memo was
to only convince the [ __ ] facebook
groups the ivermectin institutes the the
timothy mctrump pumping domestic
terrorists to get off their ass and go
save grandpa poopypants because he
couldn't save himself because he's a
[ __ ] worthless loser
that's what happened
john eastman
you [ __ ] idiot
it's ridiculous it's absolutely
ridiculous and then for them to play oh
i and the memo is great the memo is
great
so i can't wait to see i cannot wait to
see
the third video
that lauren windsor has on john eastman
i hope that it's on as soon as i'm off
here
but i'm going to go watch it you should
go to go follow her because you really
again uh yeah this she is a great
account that you have to follow you have
to keep watching
it's at la windsor
w-i-n-d-s-o-r-l-a-w-i-n-d
on twitter
and you can go to the undercurrent.tv
that's where they post some of these
videos you got to go follow them you got
to stay on top of this
so what did you guys think of the new
segment called the [ __ ] list
it's basically my show right
i just go down the [ __ ] list but i
realized hey maybe i should have a
little graphic and we should make a list
of all the stuff that we've seen on the
[ __ ] list roundup
and if you guys don't know what the [ __ ]
list roundup is you should catch that
it's on twitch
it's the stream we do we air it on
twitter too at the same time it's
simulcast on twitter and twitch but go
check out go check out our twitch stream
it's called the [ __ ] list roundup where
we go and we round up all the all the
things that are going to end up on the
[ __ ] list for the week
so i opened this thing i hope you guys
like it i hope it becomes a segment
so thanks for joining the [ __ ] list the
[ __ ] list
again thanks for joining me on the tony
michael's podcast we're running out of
time but one last time before i go
make sure on friday that you come join
us at three o'clock central four o'clock
eastern it's going to be on youtube
twitter twitch same time same place
place just on friday
we're gonna have nikki new
from tic toc the nikki news show and
instagram she's gonna be on we we talk a
lot about social media and some of the
mental health things that go along with
social media and being banned on social
media and getting followers and you know
how all that works you know the psyche
of social media a little bit we talk
about that we also talk about the
january 6
uh select committee we talk about that
on there and we talk about the rolling
stone article as well it was kind of new
when we recorded the show the other day
uh so we talked about a little bit about
the rolling stone article and these
timothy mctrump pumping domestic
terrorists
that plan the insurrection these
congress people
so go watch that on friday and always
join us here and go download the epis
the podcast
on applespotify just go to
podcast.dtonymichaels.com
or go to thetonymichaels.com
check us out there give us some support
there's some new merch on there we got
some new [ __ ] hats and stuff so go
check those out
and until next time until
next time
[ __ ] em you've been listening to the
tony michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries
i think we've made that perfectly clear
we hope you enjoyed the show and we'll
be back soon in the meantime follow tony
on social media at the tony michaels and
until next time raise a fist and repeat
after me
[ __ ] them
you